Hispanic Americans say they are fearful
and anxious in the wake of the mass
shooting in El Paso a gunman opened fire
inside a Walmart and killed 22 people
Saturday a racist manifesto posted
online before the shooting claimed quote
this attack is a response to be Hispanic
invasion of Texas since the shooting
President Trump has come under scrutiny
for his use of the word invasion to
describe migrants his critics have
linked his language to the manifesto our
newest CBS News contributor
Maria Elena Salinas joins us she's a
veteran journalist who has co-anchored
Univision's evening news program for
more than 30 years
Maria Elena welcome thanks so much for
being such a pleasure to be it's great
to have you in the family I wish it was
under better circumstances
but let's talk let's talk about this
because we heard from some people in El
Paso earlier in the broadcast Hispanics
who were who every one of them
articulated so eloquently how fearful
they are about the climate in this
country what have you heard I think
something very similar I think what they
what they're feeling is fear disbelief
and anger even though there's been fear
before maybe it was fear of being
separated from your family now they fear
for their lives and you know at some
other point its disbelief because they
can't understand why is this happening
to them in their community a welcoming
community a community that lives in
harmony with their neighbors south of
the border and they're angry because
they believe they were targeted in
revenge for being sort of like ground
zero for the immigration debate and for
the separation of families they
mentioned a militia an armed militia who
was there just a few months ago who got
there armed and said we're here
representing President Trump to stop the
invasion that is similar language that
we saw in the manifesto and that is
similar language that we have heard from
the president then of course Veronica
Escobar representative Escobar told me
that her and her constituents don't feel
that this is a matter of partisan
politics but a matter
a humanitarian matter people are not
being seen as humans is this just elpizo
though what are you hearing from other
communities I think that this is across
the board I spoke to lead community
leaders and and leading organizations in
California and Arizona in Arizona
lucha told me that this is
things that they have been fearing for a
long time they say that people in their
community are afraid to go out she told
me the story of a young lady who said I
was planning on going to warm up with my
mother and now I'm afraid to go to any
public space but you know Arizona is a
very resilient community and they're
very active very proactive and they are
already planning not only to have
different ceremonies to honor those who
were killed but also to go out there and
get people mobilized and get them to to
vote and in California
Cheerilee another organization it told
me something very interesting she said
that the fear has been there for a long
time again since the president came into
office and and what they are feeling is
that people feel unprotected it's not
only that they feel threatened but they
feel unprotected because they feel that
that that rhetoric and that agenda has
extended to all the institutions in the
country there's 57 million over 57
million Latinos in this country most of
them born in this country how do you
counter those fears and also the
rhetoric that we've heard from our
president I think you counter that by
telling your story and by using your
voice and I'm glad you mentioned that
because the majority are Americans and
people need to understand that Latinos
are Americans too and there seems to be
a perception out there that Latinos are
immigrants or that they don't belong
here and that could be farther from from
the truth 60% of American citizens born
in the u.s. under the 30% are
naturalized citizens they have just as
much right as anyone else that became a
naturalized citizen like Melania Trump
for example so you know they need to be
seen as Americans and they need to stop
feeling threatened and feeling like they
are foreigners in their own country
marina we saw in the graphic just there
that the Latinos make up 18% of US
population right do they have a sense of
their political power do you think I
think they do have a sense of their
political power but at the same time
there's many people that don't go out
and vote you know the percentage of
people that go out and vote the turnout
is very low among among Latinos but that
has been changing in in the last
elections
it's changing not on a national level
but you see it in Arizona you see it in
Nevada you see it in in in in Florida in
California during the midterm elections
we saw a tremendous increase in voter
registration and and in people going out
to voter turnout especially among young
Latinos who are the ones that are really
driving now the political force in the
community
Maria Elena Salinas thank you so much
for joining us we look forward to seeing
more of you thank you it's my pleasure